there are laws in the United States uh
that require the president to deny
illegal entry there is definitely some
sort of policy or plan with the
Democrats to bring in all of these
people they are putting stress on the
system but the hope is if they give them
enough stuff they will become Democrat
voters I don't think that's a grand
conspiracy I think it's fairly obvious
and most people are kind of saying it
under their breath in this town but
they're going after Elon because Elon
has bought Twitter and allowed most of
us to know that there's a problem here
in the first place uh Elon then
retweeted a video of Greg Abbott on Fox
News and of course this really this all
escalated about two weeks ago because
Greg Abbott decided that he was going to
protect the border of Texas because the
federal government refuses to do their
own job so Elon Musk retweeted a video
and he wrote absolutely true and let's
show you that video from Fox right now
Biden says he needs Congress uh to give
him the power to do whatever he need
needs to do to secure the border the
fact is as we all saw from what
president Trump did the president of the
United States has the power I must
emphasize this uh there is an obligation
there are laws in the United States uh
that require the president to deny
illegal entry of any illegal immigrant
and then if they do get into the United
States he has a legal obligation to
detain those illegal immigrants Joe
Biden is failing at both of those duties
and that's exactly what gives Texas the
Authority uh to make sure that we can
step up and secure our own border and
protect our own State through self the
laws are on the books we have a border
the president is supposed to defend it
and once we have all the illegals here
they are supposed to be rounded up and
kicked out the the very notion of a
sanctuary state or a sanctuary city is
not legal in and of itself and we now
know that plenty of people who are
living in these cities who are seeing
their services go to other people and
their tax dollars go to other people
like the 53 million dollar worth of
credit card uh dollars that they are
going to give to the illegals in New
York City we covered that yesterday
people are actually starting to be
pissed